[Musique]
et direction les états unis à six jours
du scrutin présidentiel la campagne est
dans sa dernière ligne droite le
candidat démocrate joe biden a voté à
son tour par anticipation dans son fief
du deleware donald trump s'apprête à
donner un meeting dans moins d'une heure
dans l'arizona est la crise sanitaire
est au coeur des échanges pendant cette
campagne mais pas seulement on retrouve
tout de suite notre envoyé spécial
stéphanie de murs rue stéphanie bonjour
très heureux de vous retrouver
depuis new york alors le coronavirus un
sujet omniprésent dans la campagne
présidentielle
oui olivier tout à fait bon soir tout
d'abord le coronavirus on ne parle que
de cela ici aussi puisque les états unis
en régissent malheureusement un nombre
record de cas à l'instar de l'europe et
de la france ces derniers jours pour
atteindre je cite un le secrétariat de
la santé un nouveau pic critique
plus de soixante treize mille 200 cas
ont été recensés et ray pour la journée
hier atteignant le chiffre on nous l'a
donnée tout à l'heure d'un demi million
de cas en juste une semaine aux états
unis à new york où je me trouve la vie
n'est plus là même le new york on
connaissait tous avant qu'on ait
apprécié bien s'est terminée en tout cas
pour l'instant
certains quartiers vont être confiné à
l'instar de brooklyn et où le queens
confinement partiel les restaurants sont
quasiment tous fermés en tout cas on
peut difficilement trouver des
restaurants où l'on peut s'asseoir pour
dîner tranquillement il faut faire de la
vente à emporter ici
les commerces pareil tourner un régime
très lent la moitié des capacités
seulement les new yorkais traumatisés
par les vingt-trois mille morts lors de
la première vague quittent la ville
faisant chuter les prix de l'immobilier
ou comprend aussi pourquoi la crise
sanitaire est devenu l'un des tous
premiers sujets de cette campagne
présidentielle les démocrates joe banner
en tête en profite évidemment pour tirer
à boulet rouge sur la stratégie de
donald trump qui jugent désastreuse
jordan a d'ailleurs été reçu aujourd'hui
par les autorités sanitaires nationales
du pays pour le briefer sur la crise
sanitaire écouter joe biden qui en a
profité à nouveau pour critiquer son
adversaire républicain
nous avons déjà perdu plus de 220 mille
vies avec ce virus mais ce gouvernement
a baissé les bras
ce week end le chef de cabinet de la
maison blanche marque windows a déclaré
à la télévision qu'ils agitaient le
drapeau blanc il avait rendu les armes
il a dit je cite nous n'allons pas
contrôler la pandémie fin de citation
le peuple américain mérite bien mieux
que cela regardez ce qui s'est passé la
nuit dernière à houma après tron après
la fin du meeting de trump des centaines
de personnes dont des citoyens âgées et
des enfants se sont retrouvés coincés
dans un froid glacial pendant dix heures
des gens ont fini à l'hôpital
cette image et le titiller de toute la
gestion de crise du président train il
prend des engagements
il fait beaucoup de grandes déclarations
mais elles ne tiennent pas la route
il fait sa séance photo il s'en va il
laisse à tous les autres les
conséquences de son absence de plan
sérieux on dirait bien que ça ne le
préoccupe à bout et plus il reste au
pouvoir - il est responsable
ça suffit il est temps de changer la naf
stratège alors donné 38 n'est pas du
tout d'accord avec cette voix là ces
critiques de la part des démocrates ils
pensent au contraire que les
restrictions trop ses vertus
l'économique ça fait finalement beaucoup
plus de dégâts que le virus lui-même
donald trump qui promet de son côté que
la pandémie sera bientôt terminé et
accuse son opposant mais aussi les
médias mainstream comme il dit
d'effrayer les américains et donc d'
exagérées pour gagner des voix écoutée
nous avons eu affaire à deux événements
slinky joey tête en bas et ils ont dit
vous devez sortir de ce sous sol
alors il a voyagé du deleware jusqu'à un
tout petit point de la pennsylvanie et
il a fait son discours et il a dit qu'il
ne faisait pas ce genre de rallye à
cause du coc vide vous savez non il ne
les fait pas parce que personne ne se
présente c'est pour ça que personne ne
vient ce kovi kovi kovi d' c'est tout ce
dont ils parlent
les fausses nouvelles kovi kovi kovi d'
c'est tout ce dont ils parlent
les progrès que nous avons faits dans ce
domaine aussi nous le comprenons nous
savons que nous devons protéger nos
aînés et nous les protégeons nous
disposons des meilleurs tests au monde
c'est pourquoi nous montrons tant de cas
parce que nous faisons plus de tests que
quiconque mais nous nous en sortons très
bien oh excusez moi
suis-je là n'est ce pas je suis là aussi
alors on l'aura compris un les deux
candidats ont vraiment des stratégies
complètement opposés sur le sujet alors
que l'un continue à sillonner les états
unis donald trump est aujourd'hui en
arizona son opposant démocrates lui
reste toujours chez lui dans le delaware
pour dit il je cite ne pas générer
d'événements super propagateur en termes
de virus je tends ainsi on l'aura
compris une pierre dans le jardin du
locataire de la maison blanche alors
stéphanie vous nous le disent y ait une
campagne sur fond de crise sanitaire
mais aussi sur fond de nouvelles émeutes
avec une nouvelle nuit de violences à
philadelphie
oui absolument olivier seconde nuit de
violences à philadelphie deux jours
après la mort de cet afro américain de
27 ans tué par deux policiers alors que
selon c'est jason de police il détenait
un couteau qu'il ne voulait pas lâcher
ils se montraient donc menaçant seconde
nuit d'émeute notamment à port richmond
dans le nord-est de philadelphie où on a
exhorté les habitants à rester chez eux
de nombreux magasins ont été saccagés
pillés
la maison blanche a offert un soutien
aux forces fédérales un gouvernement de
pennsylvanie tout en condamnant avec
beaucoup de ferveur les pillards des
émeutes qui sont dit-il donald trump le
résultat de la politique des démocrates
contre la police écouter les émeutes à
philadelphie sont le dernier produit en
date de la guerre des libéraux
démocrates contre la police le maintien
de l'ordre public est une profession
extrêmement dangereuses et des milliers
d'agents ont perdu la vie dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions
l' usage de la force meurtrière doit
toujours faire l'objet d'une enquête
complète
il faut se conformer au fait quelle que
soit la direction où il mène afin
d'assurer des conséquences juste et
équitable aux états unis les conflits se
résolvent en passant par les tribunaux
et le système judiciaire
nous ne pouvons pas laisser la loi aux
mains des émeutiers
l'administration trump est fier de
soutenir les forces de l'ordre et se
tient prête sur demande à déployer les
ressources fédérales nécessaires afin de
mettre un terme à ces émeutes
est accusée de laxisme notamment par ses
détracteurs sur les réseaux sociaux au
joe biden interrogé aujourd'hui sur ces
émeutes à philadelphie affirmé je suis
que les pillards n'avez aucune excuse
merci beaucoup stéphanie de nous faire
vivre au plus près du terrain cette
campagne nous nous retrouvons bien
évidemment dès demain pour continuer à
suivre avec vous l'élection
présidentielle américaine
[Musique]